yeah
Arya's are her world when I'm singing I
feel different like a new me Linda and
Talisa studies opera in Cape Town sup
already positive so does 26 year old T
silica mana a promising bass-baritone
if Revere I grew up in difficulty I grew
up in poverty there was a time where my
mom and dad both didn't work but they
tried to make sure that there's
something on the table for us to eat
Tesla was raised in a Township like
someone in for black South Africans high
unemployment and lack of access to
health care led some here to turn to a
life of crime linda hasn't had it easy
either
she's only able to study opera because
she received a scholarship she's the
first one in her family to attend
university and she's studying at the
renowned University of Cape Town when I
had on that the you City College of
Music took me I was screaming my lungs
out
scholarships are allowing more and more
young people from the townships to get a
university education this is the first
time Tesla's parents have been to Cape
Town they always wanted their son to get
a good education one which would provide
financial security they never imagined
he'd be a singer but now they're
impressed I never thought that yeah both
his mother perfect according Tesla
introduces them to one of his teachers
they'll be able to feed you he'll be
able to provide some bread home ok ok
that's music times are changing it's
just a matter of keeping on believing in
him yes this is Talent I'm telling you
he's super stylin maybe he's so having
to sing at the United Nations yes yes
you know that's one of the big offices
the biggest during the apartheid era
blacks weren't allowed to attend
performances in Cape Town's Opera House
they couldn't even dream of performing
there but today in this very building
Tesla's parents are about to experience
another debut they're attending their
first opera and the lead roles are being
played by none other than Tesla and
Linda
this is my first sort of beat role this
could be my chance to show them what I
have performing at the Cape Town Opera
House is part of the singer studies and
it's helped to launch the international
careers of some past graduates
I'll probably in the United States but I
also want to be a loss of an audition in
places like London
you know I want to work serac so that my
parents could be the children and I
could be the parents one day I'll be
able to to sing for you to send the
message of being a girl who grew up in
their Township and then made it to the
met in New York one day it'll come true
I know